ya todo está listo para la reunión de
los líderes de las siete naciones más
ricas del mundo
el lugar escogido Hiroshima
una ciudad japonesa con la huella de la
guerra con un conflicto a las puertas de
la Unión Europea bloque comunitario que
cuenta con tres países miembros del g7
Francia Italia y Alemania uno de los
temas obligados será Ucrania y nuevas
sanciones contra Rusia en Hiroshima el
g7 garantizará a Ucrania nuestro apoyo
inquebrantable durante el tiempo que sea
necesario la guerra en Ucrania preocupa
al g7 La amenaza nuclear está presente
por lo que la no proliferación de armas
de destrucción masiva también se
discutirá pero en Japón este tema es
sensible no solo por los ataques
nucleares contra Hiroshima y nagasaki en
1945 también porque este país es el
tercero con más centrales nucleares en
el mundo
manifestantes de Corea del Sur país
invitado a la reunión sostienen
pancartas que rezan no bombardear El
Pacífico frente a la sede de Electric
Power Company holding que vertirá agua
radioactiva de la planta de fukushima en
el mar
el océano Pacífico no le pertenece a
Japón estamos aquí hoy para enviar el
mensaje de que Japón no tiene derecho a
verter agua radioactiva otros temas en
la agenda del g7 serán la adopción de
medidas económicas seguras y resilientes
basadas en la alianza con el sur global
que ayuden a los mercados emergentes y
la amenaza urgente de la crisis
climática